我看到那个李行亮为了争取女儿的抚养权，
在车上哭着说，
闺女和我是一样的人，
她是我的影子，
我家里没人了，
你们都跟我不一样，
只有她跟我一样。
我看见他就像看见自己，
那一瞬间我没绷住啊，
我专门写了一个稿子，
嗯，
跟大家聊一聊这个事情啊。
我相信其实你们也跟我一样的，
有这种共情啊，
心疼了，
尤其是对两个素未谋面的孩子，
他们将来可能面对的人生也产生了深深的担忧。
我们今天先从法律的角度谈一谈他们可能会面临的各种选项，
希望他们全方位的了解法律之后，
在冷静的、
慎重的、
周全的去安排彼此和孩子的未来生活，
就他俩，
不管怎么安排，
嗯，
咱们呢，
作为吃瓜的群众啊，
只要他们能够自洽，
他们自己能过得好，
不违法，
不犯罪，
不骗我们口袋里的钱，
我们都要平静的接受，
尊重他们的选择。
嗯，
各位也不要入戏太深。
第一个法律知识点就是一般情况下，
年满8周岁以上的子女，
如果双方家长都想要孩子的抚养权。
的话，
法官会充分尊重孩子的自己的选择，
根据孩子的真实意愿来判决抚养权的归属啊，
我在网上查了一下，
他们那个女儿是已经满9周岁了，
所以孩子她自己是可以选择的，
但是把这个选择权放在孩子身上，
这件事情本身对孩子来说可能是一种伤害，
所以作为家长一定要先评估孩子的心理，
如果说孩子心思敏感脆弱，
那就不要去逼孩子选，
作为家长自己先商量好，
现实生活中，
两个子女的家庭如果要分开，
大概率下就是一家判一个，
两个孩子同时判给一方的概率是比较小的，
所以呃，
作为妈妈心里要有这样的一个心理准备，
所以不要太执着于两个孩子都归自己这件事情，
非得让一个孩子自己去选择这件事情。
嗯，
另外一个法律知识点，
我看到很多网友在心里打抱不平啊，
说麦琳在公司有90%的股权，
而李行亮却没有显示在股东名册里，
这里其实不重要，
就只要是领了结婚证之后在设立的公司，
哪怕说卖林占百分之百的股权，
实际上还是夫妻共同财产啊，
除非他们有白纸黑。
司的约定说这个公司的股权按照什么比例来分，
否则的话，
正常就是夫妻两口子正常分割吧，
谁在那个工商登记登记百分比这个事儿不重要，
他有一个点是李行亮，
他在节目里面口头说过，
如果呃，
我俩要是分开的话，
3/4的财产归你，
那这样一个口头的承诺在法律上有没有约束力呢？
在法律上口头的承诺是没有约束力的，
换句话说，
如果说他想反悔的话，
到最后还是正常的来分割，
但是从舆论这个角度来说的话，
可能遵守这个承诺对于李行亮的将来的事业来说会更有利一些，
但这只是我个人的一个判断啊。
第4个知识点是关于李行亮的很多歌曲的收益，
只要是在婚姻关系存续期间已经变现的，
或者说已经签了合同，
确定了可以变现的，
都属于夫妻共同财产，
以上呢，
是我能够想到的一些法律上的问题，
大家有什么问题也可以在评论区来探讨。
其实最后才是我这次发作品想真正表达的东西，
我不知道有没有人跟我一样。
现在很担心麦迪括弧啊，
这里没有反讽，
没有调侃，
就是担心。
嗯，
可能这个时候大家会骂我，
说装圣母婊。
坦率的讲，
我之所以会担心他，
是因为我真的可以从他身上看到自己以前的样子。
我也有过那种始终觉得男朋友不够爱我，
不够关心我，
而我通过动不动就说分手的态度，
去一次一次试图去证明他还在乎我，
他还是会回来求和的。
如果对方晾着我。
我没有及时化解这样的心理的那个矛盾，
我会难过到睡不着，
吃不下，
甚至神经性呕吐，
会说出各种各样的话来伤害对方，
道德绑架对方，
甚至会全盘否定我们之间的一切。
就当我看到麦琳一遍一遍跟李行亮提离婚的时候，
那一刻我好像看到了曾经的自己。
其实我心里知道他不是真的想离婚，
你们也知道他不是真的想离婚，
我相信你们身边有千千万万个麦林，
就像张庆林老师说，
很多人给他发私信，
内容是我的妈妈是麦林，
我的闺蜜是麦林，
甚至有人非常坦诚的说，
我就是麦灵。
其实谩骂和攻击她对我们是没有意义的，
我们需要做的是分析一下我们怎么做才能找到属于自己最舒服的家人也最舒服的那个状态。
你想想他，
他不是一个演员，
他就是一个素人，
现在这种铺天盖地对他的谩骂和攻击，
因为我是经历过网暴的人啊，
我认为绝大多数人都承受不住他现在所面临的这些谩骂和攻击。
有的时候呢，
我设想一下，
如果把我自己家里的这些鸡零狗碎的事情搬到聚光灯下，
逐针去解读、
去审查的时候，
我会觉得后背一阵发凉。
我说句难听点的话，
万一出什么事情，
这些谩骂和攻击他的人该如何自处呢？
所以姐妹们啊，
咱们结个善缘，
管住自己的嘴，
不要泄愤谩骂，
不要人身攻击，
可以善意的发表意见，
分享自己怎么从卖灵量的状态把自己拯救出来，
变得越来越好的经验，
总结自己的心态变好的那个转念的时刻，
希望千千万万个麦灵能看到自己痛苦的同时，
也能抽离出来，
去体察一下身边的家人，
包括爱人，
包括孩子，
能够去体察一下他们的痛苦。
其实我们最终的目的还是想获得幸福，
有的时候获得幸福这条路会很曲折，
但我们现在所看到的卖淫，
毕竟是他三四十年的人生当中的短短的几个小时，
谁能说他以后就找不到那个可以跟爱人跟孩子好好去相处的那条道路呢？
对吧，
总之吧，
咱们结个善缘，
希望他们能够找到属于自己最舒服的一个状态。
也希望这两个孩子。
能够获得幸福。